tall-tale gold medalist Ryan Lochte has
started as forgiveness to her with an
appearance on the new season on Dancing
with the Stars if everyone's dance then
everything's fine and this time he was
really almost mugged
there it is protestors come onto the
stage to grab by security great takes
him down yeah
Mambo number 5 oh I wonder if that
protesters gonna tell everyone that he
was almost robbed
I mean he's been on nearly a whole month
since Ryan Lochte is controversial
run-in with a Brazilian gas station and
now he's dancing on the TV I don't know
how to feel about him do is it time to
forgive him do we forgive him are we not
okay with him what are you guys oh whoa
no it's a very strong opinion a very
strong opinions a lot of swearing in
Portuguese from the audience what do you
think I'm tired of the attitude I don't
think he has anything to be forgiven for
what he's a hero he's an American that's
how we do it we go to your country win a
gold medal piss on it and then go to the
Fox Trot back home Austria
I'm tired of Brazil I'm tired of Brazil
with your perfect asked women and your
perfect beaches you know I mean I grew
up in the Bay Area do you know how many
capoeira circles I had to pretend to be
interested in growing up bit Brazil
points yeah mr. Louie I think he's
better at dancing around the truth
oh but he did go to Brazil and pee on
their things I mean if I another country
too that if I missed the toilet bowl at
my mom's house I get in trouble okay
let's this guy pissed on one of brazil's
most important landmarks a gas station
door what I'm saying is instead of
focusing on making America great again
let's make Brazil great for once any
points for that I think well America I
would like to see him dance off a cliff
this is so interesting the way America
punishes its white men on what's that
Bill Clinton you lied under oath well
you can be damn sure you'll continue to
be president for the next two years
yeah Marty you vandalized a toilet and
then blame the poor Brazilians well you
can be damn sure we are going to put you
sternly on one of the most highest
grossing TVs